the heading is the heading is reducing
balance loads okay let me explain what's
going on when you borrow money of any
kind we say oh I'm getting a loan right
or someone is loaning money to me now
the particular kind of thing we're
looking at you just have a look at the
sums of money that you're looking at and
the time scale that you're looking at
we're looking at that specific kind of
load which we call okay now there's an
interesting story behind why the word
mortgage is what it is thank you
now mortgages because they have on such
large sums of money and because they go
over such large periods of time number 1
bit confusing they're confusing like I
have lots of friends even people who
work in the finance industry and they
get their you know monthly statement
about their mortgage or whatever load it
is and they honestly have no idea what
any of the numbers mean and it kind of
like um tens of thousands of dollars are
going out of my bank account every year
and I don't really know why I just kind
of trust the think is doing the right
thing you don't need me to convince you
that's a dangerous position to the end
now just have a look at this with me and
we're gonna calculate some bits together
and understand what this is about this
is saying for you if you borrow say
three hundred twenty thousand dollars
that's how much I borrowed pretty much
when I bought my home okay if you borrow
that amount and you plan to pay off that
amount over this number of years so for
example mine was about 25 years that was
the initial period of the loan that I
agreed to okay
then someone is gonna crunch the numbers
and said for that amount of money in
fact I'm gonna scroll over this that
amount of money and for this amount of
time each month you can expect to have
that amount pulled out of your bank
account okay
now I'm trying to draw your attention to
this end right on the page because you
guys know unlike any other of the
mathematics courses when you get your
exam like the reason why your exam is
like a big fat booklet and you write in
the lines in that kind of thing is cuz I
let the HSC looks like okay now your HSC
is like that because
wants you to do what I just did they'll
give you a table
they will pose you a question like use
the table to find the blah blah blah
blah blah and when you see you say okay
this amount goes to here this amount
goes to here I've said many times before
marking even though in mathematics we
like to say it's very objective compared
to some other subjects that I won't name
marking is a flexible thing remember I
told you um some of the questions we
looked at just now we're done really
really poorly
why are you here I spoke to the Markus
who actually were in charge of the
market under the time a question just
like this was done so poorly as a
question out of three if you did this if
you just drew arrows like that and
didn't write anything you've got a mark
just for drawing arrows now just think
about this for a second what a marks for
like put yourself in the position of a
teacher mark off what are you giving a
mantra if someone is demonstrating
understanding then they merit the mark
now can you see yeah I haven't you know
actually written now what they are
supposed to be able to use that for a
purpose but I'm pretty demonstrate I
know how to read this table what does
that make sense so when I say school
over highlight draw arrows that can
think I look looking around it's really
useful to help you understand and if you
get lucky then we can do some marks for
it okay now think about this to me I'm
get your calculator out three hundred
and twenty thousand dollars this
particular table has been constructed at
a particular interest rate can you see
it read look carefully
very good eight point five percent if
you can screw your eyes up now I'm kind
of interested in where these numbers
came from I just want to understand a
little bit okay so think about this for
me three hundred twenty thousand dollars
three hundred and twenty thousand
dollars if I was charged 8.5% interests
on that how do I do this with compound
interest if you doing a lot of simple
interest recently how do I do this with
compound interest yeah it's one plus
it's going to be that rate 0.085 i close
the bracket
so the power of however many time
periods they are right and then that's
going to be how much they're going to
have to charge me right now you have I
offer you get your calculator out can
you go ahead and work out what that
number is
go on have a guy press the buttons be
careful with your power button there get
the index in the right spot now you
might be looking at a number and your
sense check might be saying really
really let me write for you the number
that I'm looking at this is the number
I've got and you're like hold on a
second
that can't be like that so a million
dollars are you for real okay now
there's two things you want to notice
here number one yes that number is huge
you haven't pressed the buttons wrong
compound interest is a big deal the more
not money that's in there the faster it
grows interest okay
secondly this is a heck of a long time
right like 25 years that's a long time
to put money in a bank or from their
point of view to put money into you
right so this is how much interest we've
got to pay however I'm not gonna pay
that amount back right because what was
the title of this some petty you reduce
you balance so the whole idea is this is
what would happen this is what would
happen if I just got the loan and then
just didn't touch it like didn't pay off
any of it right it's just gonna keep on
getting interest interest faster and
faster it's gonna get to there but the
whole premise of this table is that I'm
making monthly repayments just make
sense okay now think about this let's
come to the table now ah look at that
number two thousand five hundred seventy
six how much am I actually going to pay
hmm how do we work this out
it's a monthly amount right two five
seven six and 72 cents right it's a
monthly amount and their 25 years how
many months are there in 25 years well
it's gonna be 12 times 25 whatever that
happens to be okay
which i think is 300 isn't it so when
you multiply
that number by 300 what do you get wait
what Hey
yeah that sounds more like it 7-3 hold
on there's a decimal point there right
I heard hold on 737 nine - why
yeah I think you've yeah yeah yeah I
knew it started with a seven but okay
say it one more time seven seven yeah
yeah we're looking at this have I got
some sense no that's it
okay what do you think of that number
what do you think of nmo okay I I think
two things when I look at that number
number one that's a whole lot better
than two and a half million dollars but
number two like in proportion to what I
borrowed in proportion to what I
borrowed
how much is it more than what I borrowed
it's more than double double would be
six hundred forty thousand and this is
way more than that okay now eight point
five percent right it doesn't sound like
that big a deal but on large sums of
money for long amounts of time yeah
that's actually not that far from what
I'm going to end up paying by the end of
the life of this loan okay yeah law for
living in Sydney because here very much
of $300,000 these days okay sir
so this amount here it's quite a lot
larger why is it not exactly 320,000
it's because interest is being
calculated but I'm paying off bits to
reduce that amount of interest okay so
it's kind of if you like this is how
much I would pay if I pet it off
instantly if I had that amount of money
okay this is how much I would pay if I
waited the maximum number of time amount
of time and then paid it all off and
this guy is kind of in the middle
because I don't want to do either of
those well I can't do that it's just not
possible
and um you're crazy if you want to do
that so this is an average in between
that make sense